We're now moving on to cover interdomain
routing or routing between ASes. Recall that internet
routing consists of routing between tens of
thousands of independently operated networks, or autonomous systems.
Each of these networks operate in their
own self-interest, and have independent economic and performance
objectives, and yet they must cooperate to provide
global connectivity so that when you're sitting at
home, you can retrieve content that might
be hosted at the Georgia Tech network. Now,
each independently operated network is called an autonomous
system, or AS. And each AS advertises reachability
to some destination by sending what are
called route advertisements or announcements. The protocol that
ASes use to exchange these route advertisements is
called the Border Gateway Protocol, or simply, BGP.
A route advertisement has many important attributes, but
for now, let's just talk about three. Now a
router here, let's say on the Comcast network, might
receive a route advertisement, typically from its neighboring AS.
That route advertisement might contain a destination prefix,
such as the IP prefix for Georgia Tech. Then
it might contain what's called a next hop IP
address, which is the IP address of the router
that Comcast router must send traffic to, to send
traffic along that route. Typically that next hop IP address
is the IP address for the first router in
the neighboring network. And Comcast router knows how to reach
that next hop IP address because its border router
and the border router in the neighboring AS are on
the same subnet. Typically this might be a /30
subnet, therefore this IP address is reachable from Comcast's border.
A third important attribute is whats called the
AS path which is a sequence of what are
called AS numbers, that describe the route to
the destination. Now strictly speaking, the AS path is
nothing more than the sequence of ASes that the route traversed to reach the
recipient AS. So for example, Georgia Tech's AS number is
2637 and Abilene's is 10578. So the AS path that Comcast
would hear if it received a route advertisement
from Abilene for Georgia Tech, would be 10578
followed by 2637. So in the remainder of
the lesson we'll look at other BGP route
attributes. But these are essentially the three most
important because they describe how to stitch together
an interdomain path to a global destination. So
we have the destination IP prefix for the destination
that a router might want to send traffic to. The
next hop, which is the IP address for the router
for the next hop along the path. And finally,
the AS path, which is the sequence of ASes that
the route traversed en route to the AS that's
hearing the announcement. The last AS number on the AS
path is often called the origin AS, because that is
the AS that originated the advertisement for this IP prefix.
In this case, the origin AS is 2637, or Georgia Tech,
because it is the AS that originated the announcement for this prefix.